I have this 4 by 4
matrix, A, here.
And let's see if we can figure
out its determinant, the
determinant of A.
And before just doing it the way
we've done it in the past,
where you go down one of the
rows or one of the columns--
and you notice, there's no 0's
here, so there's no easy row
or easy column to take
the determinant by.
We could have gone down this
row and do all the
submatrices, but this becomes
pretty involved.
You end up doing four 3 by 3
determinants, and then each of
those are composed of three
2 by 2 determinants.
It becomes a pretty
hairy process.
Let's see if we can use some
of the realizations we've
discovered in the last
two videos to
simplify this process.
Well, one of the realizations is
that row operations, or if
you subtract-- let me write it
this way-- if you replace row
j with, let's say, row j minus
some scale or multiple, times
row i, it does not change
the determinant of A.
We saw that, I think it
was two videos ago.
So this is a pretty
big realization.
We can do these type of row
operations and it won't change
the determinant.
The other realization we had
was that these upper
triangular matrices, you can
figure out their determinant.
So what does upper triangular
look like?
Let me just review it.
The upper triangular--
everything below the diagonal.
So let's say the diagonal has--
let me just draw its
terms like that.
These are some non-zero terms.
Oh, they don't have to be.
Then upper triangular,
everything below the diagonal
is a 0, and everything above the
diagonal probably isn't a
0, but you never know.
But they're non-zero terms, so
all the red stuff here is
non-zero, all this stuff
in green is 0.
And I didn't touch on it in that
video, but there is also
such a thing as a lower
triangular, that you might
have guessed how it looks.
Everything above the main
diagonal is 0, so this is the
main diagonal right here, all
the way down like that.
All of these guys are going
to be non-zero.
All of that's going to be
non-zero, and then the 0's are
going to be above the
diagonal, like that.
We saw in the last video that
the determinant of this guy is
just equal to the product of the
diagonal entries, which is
a very simple way of finding
a determinant.
And you could use the same
argument we made in the last
video to say that the same is
true of the lower triangular
matrix, that its determinant
is also just the product of
those entries.
I won't prove it here, but you
can use the exact same
argument you used in the video
that I just did on the upper
triangular.
So given this, that the
determinant of this is just
the product of those guys, and
that I can perform row
operations on this guy and not
change the determinant, maybe
a simpler way to calculate this
determinant is to get
this guy into an upper
triangular form, and then just
multiply the entries
down the diagonal.
So let's do that.
So we want to find the
determinant of A.
Let me rewrite A right here.
It's 1, 2, 2, 1, 1, 1, 2, 4,
2, 2, 7, 5, 2, minus 1, 4,
minus 6, 3.
Now let's try to get this into
upper triangular form.
So let's replace the second
row with the-- so I'm just
going to keep the first
row the same.
1, 2, 2, 1.
And let's replace the second row
with the second row minus
the first row.
The second row minus the first
row is going to be equal to 1
minus 1 is 0.
So in this case the constant
is just 1.
So 1 minus 1 is 0.
2 minus 2 is 0.
4 minus 2 is 2.
2 minus 1 is 1.
Now let's replace the third row
with the third row minus 2
times the second row.
So 2 minus 2 times 1 is 0.
7 minus 2 times 2 is 3.
5 minus 2 times 2 is 1.
2 minus 2 times 1 is 0.
Let me get a good color here.
I'll do pink.
Let's replace the last row
with the last row,
essentially, plus
the first row.
You could say minus minus 1
times the first row is the
same thing as the last row
plus the first row.
So minus 1 plus 1 is 0.
4 plus 2 is 6.
Minus 6 plus 2 is minus 4.
And then 3 plus 1 is 4.
So there we have it like that.
And this guy has two 0's
here, so maybe I want
to swap some rows.
So let me swap some rows.
So if we swap rows,
what happens?
I'm going to swap the middle
two rows just for fun.
Well, not just for fun.
Because I want a pivot
entry right here.
I shouldn't say a pivot entry.
I want to do it in upper
triangular form.
So I want a non-zero
entry here.
This is a 0, so I'm going
to move this guy down.
So I'm going to keep the
top row the same.
1, 2, 2, 1.
I'm going to keep the
bottom row the same.
0, 0, 6, minus 4, 4.
And I'm going to swap these
guys right here.
So this is going to
be 0, 3, 1, 0.
And then 0, 0, 2, 1.
Now, can I just swap
entries like that?
Well, I can, but you have to
remember that when you swap
entries, your resulting
determinant is going to be the
negative of your original
determinant.
So if we swap these two guys,
the determinant of this is
going to be the negative
of this determinant.
When you swap two rows, you
just flip the sign of the
determinant.
We saw that.
That was one of the first videos
we did on these, kind
of messing with the
determinants.
Now, what do we want
to do here?
To get this guy into upper
triangular form, it'd be nice
to get this to be a 0.
So to get that to be
a 0, let me keep
everything else the same.
So I have a 1, 2, 2, 1.
I have a 0, 3, 1, 0.
The third row is 0, 0, 2, 1.
And now this last row, let me
replace it with the last row
minus 3 times this row.
So let me write it like this.
I have to carry that negative
sign as well.
So I'm going to replace this
last row with the last row
minus 2 times the second row.
want to zero it out.
So 0 minus 2 times 0 is 0.
6 minus 2 times 3 is 0.
Minus 4 minus 2 times
1 is minus 6.
And then 4 minus 2 times
0 is just 4.
We're almost there.
Now we want to zero this
guy out, so let's
replace this one.
So I'm going to keep my top
three rows the same again.
And let me see if I can write
it a little bit neater.
So my first row is 1, 2, 2, 1.
My second row is 0, 3, 1, 0.
Fourth row is 0, 0, 2, 1.
And I'm going to take
the matrix.
I haven't written the
fourth row yet.
And, of course, the negative
of this is going to be
determinant of our original
matrix, because we had swapped
those rows.
But let's replace this last row
with the last row, plus 3
times the third row.
So we get 0 plus
3 times 0 is 0.
0 plus 3 times 0 is 0.
Minus 6 plus 3 times 2 is 0.
4 plus 3 times 1 is 7.
And just like that, we have a
determinant of a matrix in
upper triangular form.
So this is going to be equal to
the product of these guys.
We can't forget our
negative sign.
Let's throw our negative sign
out there and put a
parentheses just like that.
This is going to be
the product of
that diagonal entry.
1 times 3, times 3, times 2,
times 7, which is 6 times 7,
which is 42.
So the determinant of this
matrix is minus 42, which was
pretty fast. This was a
pretty fast shortcut.
And it actually turns out it
tends to be computationally
more efficient to use these
takeaways to put things into
upper triangular form first. And
then, you know, if you do
swaps, you have to remember to
make the determinant negative.
And then just multiply
down the diagonal.
And we did that there, and
we got the determinant
as being minus 42.